hallo zusammen heute gibt ein relativ
spontanes video und kein rezept video
weil wir auf die momentane katastrophe
einfach schnell reagieren nur angenommen
bei uns schalten backhäuser gerade die
sonne aber nicht überall in deutschland
und zwar ist sein verheerende
flutkatastrophe in vielen teilen
deutschlands und das wir haben auch sehr
viele zuschauer geschrieben dass sie
haben viele zuschauer geschrieben und um
spenden hilfen gebeten
wir haben selber eine serie stiftung
schon seit ungefähr drei jahren und wir
engagieren uns für bildungseinrichtungen
für schulen kindergärten und auch diese
schulen kindergärten sind natürlich auch
vor dieser katastrophe über 90 menschen
sind inzwischen momentan stand die heute
oder gerade jetzt schon ums leben
gekommen also es ist wirklich verheerend
und wir haben es gesagt vielleicht
können wir mit unserer stiftung zusammen
helfen was cooles machen was ist
schnelles machen und unkompliziert und
schnell helfen also falls es jemand noch
nicht mitbekommen hat ich bin ja auch
kein mensch der ständig nachrichten
schaut aber das war jetzt einfach das
muss man jetzt mitbekommen und deswegen
müssen wir jetzt auch die reichweite und
möchten euch darauf aufmerksam machen es
ist einfach ganz ganz schlimmes unwetter
ganz viel regen und anfangs hat sich
glaube ich jeder über den regen gefreut
für die gärten und jetzt nimmt einfach
alles überhand und während bei uns hier
die sonne scheint überflutet einfach der
restliche teil von deutschland und
häuser stürzen ein kindergärten
krankenhäuser alles überflutet ist
teilweise schon so weit dass menschen
die gerade frisch aus einer herz-op
kommen einfach evakuiert werden müssen
und es echt richtig schlimm
und jetzt ist einfach zusammenhalt
gefragt und vor allem schnell und
unkompliziert nicht viel schnacken
möglich jetzt schnell zu helfen und
erneut zu helfen und es können mit
dieser stiftung werden uns jetzt
überlegt was machen wir und eigentlich
ist schon so unsere stiftungssatzung ist
einfach da für gesundheit ernährung
bildung das alles unterstützen
aber wenn wir uns jetzt gedacht wir
müssen jetzt schnell handeln und
deswegen möchten wir einfach von uns aus
schon mal 20.000 euro startkapital also
sofort auf das spendenkonto einzahlen
einfach als als hilfe von uns vom feld
team und möchten auch den umsatz ab
jetzt bis sonntagnacht zehn prozent des
kompletten shop umsatzes online einfach
auch direkt spenden und wir haben es
einfach ein neues spendenkonto
eingerichtet das geht dann direkt an die
flutopfer genau und da werden wir uns
informieren und schauen wer alles hilfe
braucht wo man hin spenden kann momentan
ist nämlich so dass man noch gar nicht
abschätzen kann welche sachspenden
gebraucht werden
denn die menschen sind gerade obdachlos
sind keine unterkunft falls sie aus der
umgebung kommt wäre es auch schön als
aus denen aus den flutgebieten was auch
schön wenn er dort einfach mal schaut
die freiwilligen helfer die feuerwehr an
alle einsatzkräfte für die mit essen und
decken und alle möglichen verpflegen und
versorgen könnte und wie gesagt könnt
ihr auch auf das spendenkonto selbst
einzahlen und gerne mithelfen falls er
einfach auch so wie wir aus einem
schöneren teil von deutschland kommt wo
es einfach trocken ist und du einfach
niemand betroffen und jetzt wirklich
ganz schnell und alle zusammenhalten ist
ganz ganz wichtig und bitte bitte helft
uns unterstützt uns und wie gesagt jeder
cent kommt an wir haben jetzt selber wir
fangen sofort damit 20.000 euro aus
handys welt unterstützt uns bitte wie
gesagt im shop zehn prozent bis zum ende
der woche bis zum sonntag geht direkt
dorthin und bitte unterstützt und teilt
dieses video und wie diese schon gesagt
wenn er aus der region kommt stellt die
unterkünfte und verpasste das deutsche
rote kreuz sagt weil die werden euch
bescheid sagen was die menschen jetzt
ganz ganz dringend brauchen wir werden
jetzt partner von uns anrufen rudolf von
gegen havelse mit mobiler werbung von
kitchenaid käme und mir genau an wer ist
komplett durch telefonieren und sagen
komm helft uns und ich lege
spendenbescheinigung alles kein thema
bitte so schnell als möglich
unkompliziert helft uns einfach teilt
dieses video jetzt ist zusammenhalt
gefragt und mir helfen einander
vielen dank